[Musique]
tu serais pas mandat lire par hasard oui
et c'est pas par hasard ça tu sais quoi
de rencontrer ton double ça m'est déjà
arrivé e au cours de certains de mes
concerts les deux premiers rangs sont
plaints de solides amanda lear mais
genre dans un miroir déformant
traficoter un petit peu la charge et
c'était que ça fait un peu peur je
trouves tu te trouves comment mieux qu'à
la télé oui puis à l'odeur ya spa
refrain en deux temps c'est mieux
souvent vrai et toi le matin quand il te
regarde dans la glace ça tu trouves
comment tu fais avec difficulté non
parce que le matin c'est vrai j'ai les
yeux qui sont pas tout à fait ouverts et
quand finalement je me trouve
c'est un petit peu un choc et puis après
on sollicite donc inquiéter toute petite
soeur aînée ressembler à cri à mes ouest
j'adorerais mais ouest cette auto ironie
ce sens à dérision sens de l'humour
dédramatiser aussi le sexe ça me
plaisait beaucoup et puis après je les
rencontre et ça continue est mon idole
et vous content à moi non non pas
vraiment c'était pas mon
non ce n'était pas du tout le genre de
personne qui me plaisait qui m'attirait
qu'il va signer si tu y avait une
baguette magique tu changerais quoi en
toi rien rien n'a changé et rien acheter
tout est bien content d'elle et qu'est
ce que tu as de plus sexy mon cul de
l'avis général ces frais l'amour avec
moi avec beaucoup de contraintes
il faudrait vraiment obligé et peut-être
me donner des sous en plus et si tu
étais bien payés de s'y prendre et
comment au jeu fermeraient les yeux et
je penserai quelqu'un d'autre je pense
que c'est ce que je ferai fort à très
vite c'est bon à savoir tu m'aimes un
peu quand même
il ya beaucoup d'amour il ya beaucoup de
ncc conflictuelle c'est difficile de
dire que quelqu'un comme toi
[Applaudissements]
hamon
[Musique]
ils étaient mignons petits cochons un
bien tu es né à hong kong
oui mon père marin oui brutale et d'une
britannique prix et d'une mère divorcée
oui et ce qui est élevé à neil dans la
haine des hommes
faut te dire qu'au départ j'étais quand
même assez moche
oui parce que je vais à angers comment
non c'est je porte un appareil pour
montrer les dents si j'avais les dents
qui avance et est alors évident c'était
s'est émoussée sera que je souriais
j'avais des fils de claire dans tous les
sens ça existe encore des cris et puis
j'étais trop grande et j'étais trop
maigre et donc c'était plutôt loppement
que moi je trouver moche et puis j'ai eu
de la chance d'être à une époque là
l'époque françoise hardy et sait où on
cherchait justement des mannequins
c'était paco rabanne qui m'avait demandé
des filets ils voulaient être sûrs de
leur parcours en baie non non le fil de
fer étaient partis mais je dire le côté
grande bringue des en grand manque d'un
peu maigrichonne m'a servi et comment
t'es tu retrouvé à londres dans les
années 60 dans le swinging de méchoui
alors ça c'est bizarre quand tu penses
que j'ai connu ça tu sais je parle à des
gamins anglais maintenant et il me
regarde avec des yeux comme ça mais vous
avez vraiment connu john jimi hendrix et
jon leyne et j'ai l'impression d'être un
dinosaure
je suis tellement connue j'ai beaucoup
hésité fac non tu vas me dire ce que tu
as intimement connu un dimanche huit
morts avec la langue alors
alosi jimi hendrix jim hendry que
c'était un copain il habitait à la
maison voulait rien de sexuel n'est pas
couché a nettement moins j'aurais pu
parce qu'il l'aimé assez il avait une
certaine faiblesse pour les blondes
décolorées tenir mais s'est rien passé
john lennon bryan ferry
oui et alors
et alors quoi j'ai pas il est épais
comme ça qui l'intéressé très critiqué
il m'a il m'a demandé de poser pour une
pochette de disque en sac s'était passé
il m'avait vu défiler à londres et il
avait besoin d'une fille pour sa
nouvelle projet de disque il soit un
petit peu dominatrix maîtresse
dominatrice fois un peu sado maso et
donc comme il aimait beaucoup ça il m'a
flanqué des talons comme ça
cuir noir chignon est il une guerre une
trentaire mois en laisse
derichebourg witbooi j'ai vécu avec
lippmann donc on a vécu ensemble fait
mieux ou moins bien
c'était plus imaginatifs
brian jones oui oui si brian jones --il
y habiter un certain moment à la maison
mais il était très beau mais de faire
quoi que ce soit et je faisais mais il
était quand même très il avait plutôt
besoin disons d'une maman de tendresse
d'une infirmière plutôt que d'une
maîtresse et celle des laitues la
rencontre et comment ma vie arriver chez
castel
il était ainsi entouré d'une cour comme
toujours et il a voulu connaître et il
m'a dit ah vous savez vous avez la plus
belle tête de mort que j'ai fait deux
morts moi comme si bien maquillée et
tout exprès six mois tu as vécu 15 ans
avec lui
plus on est presque 18 mai des mariés
oui et alors j'espère c'est merveilleux
avec sa femme
ah bon parce que les expédier 10 mois
voilà alors gala est le genre de femme
ou été que j'aimerais être et que je
pense toutes les femmes aimeraient y est
c'est le genre de femme qui dit si vous
êtes si mon mari est heureux avec vous
vous aimez bénédiction je veux mon mari
soit heureux quand il j'aime mon mari je
sais tout pour moi et donc si l'on
arrivera vous est venue habiter à la
maison par son verbe
quand tu arrives et le parti en voyage
de laisser même gabarit mais maudit
vraiment c'était comme à la cour de
louis xiv où on rentre on sort ont gelé
des machins l arrivée non j'arrivais
yat mans elle se trouvait brusquement
une urgence elle pas elle devait partir
en voyage elle revenue au bout d'un mois
l'aller en grèce ou en suisse elle
revenait pour sa cure mois sont là
justement je devais rentrer à londres
donc c'était on se croise on passait
quand même deux trois jours ensemble
pour que la bonne harmonie rei et
c'était formidable et d'alice toujours
que dali après avoir passé trois mois
avec moi l'été il est tombé dans les
bras de sa femme à lui manquer ils
étaient contents de la revois galice et
est quoiqu'il eût pu élever chez toi le
côté androgyne
non c'était autre chose c'était ils me
voyaient vulnérables y savais que
j'avais souffert que j'étais angoissé
l'air de quoi
mais j'étais très angoissée je suis
encore très très
amanda lear
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
amanda bon choix amanda bon choix on va
commencer par des choses un petit peu
tragique
amanda vont rentrer de new york je
rentre de new york un effet et j'ai
beaucoup de mal à rentrer je dois dire
c'était s'était pas marrant parce que
j'ai je suis allé là-bas bénédiction de
peinture à new york et le jour même de
mon vernissage c'était justement le
mardi 11 et c'était quand il ya eu
l'attentât
ce qui fait que j'étais dans le sud de
manhattan puisque toutes les galeries de
peinture sont dans le quartier qui
s'appelle chelsea et le village c'est le
relax et donc j'étais à quoi une
vingtaine de blocs des détours et comme
c'était 10 heures du matin j'ai tentant
d'accrocher une étoile dans la galerie
et boum badaboum tout ça est arrivé ce
qui fait que non je pense pas que ce
soit mon équipe était sûrement ça se
pourrait mais donc on a regardé et on a
regardé tout ça en direct et je dois
dire que c'était resté bouche bée
je croyais pas ce qui va et ce qui
arrive est quoi et puis ensuite donc il
ya eu c'était quand les tours se sont
écroulés c'est là qu'il a eue c'était au
menu âge tu sais de fumée de brugière
dhr qui envahit littéralement toutes les
rues de manhattan
alors là je suis rentré à moineaux tel
couvert de poussière et tout et je dois
dire cependant toute une semaine je suis
resté donc là bas dans mon hôtel
l'aéroport était fermé
il n'y avait pas d'avion pour rentrer
tous les jours je téléphonais en france
alors je commençais à trouver le temps
long parce que j'ai je veux rentrer non
mais je te dirais une chose c'est que
bon à part cet événement est
épouvantable j'ai été frappé par la
solidarité des new yorkais de si on dit
toujours que new york est une ville
frivole marescaux pognon est tous là
tous les new yorkais vraiment été là il
faisait la queue pour donner leur sang
il est rentré solidaire dans la rue tous
les soirs il a allumé des bougies
il y avait des veillées et je me suis
rendu compte à quel point
en plus le maire giuliani a dit à la
télé à tous les new yorkais retourner au
boulot fait comme si rien n'était on va
pas leur montrer qu'on est à terre qu'on
est con est foutue continuer la vie
continue à new york alors c'est curieux
parce qu'au bout de deux jours donc la
ville s'est scindée en deux une partie
avait tout bay route quoi 20 mètres et
l'autre partie le
vous avez repris les gens couraient dans
broadway dans manhattan et tout ça parte
je me demande si tu portes un peu lâche
comme ou non seulement qu'est ce qui
t'arrive des choses assez hard et tu vas
à new york est la ville et à feu sont
attendus oui c'est vrai un mandat on
peut dire que cette tragédie survient
après une autre
nous n'en parlerons pas un mandat voilà
on va parler d'un film non nous n'en
parlons pas juste un mot en passant
c'est que ya eu une odeur dans les rues
de new york et le vent a tourné et il ya
eu cette odeur de crabes de brûler de
cendres envahi les rues et c'est ça qui
m'a le plus moi bouleversée c'est que
c'était grâce à l'odeur qui me rappelait
ma maison et samassa beaucoup bouleversé
ne l'ont parlerons pas mon beurre et
après de me trouver là-bas coincé alors
je te dis pas l'aéroport
tout le monde essayait d'embarquer sur
un avion il y avait marie christine
marek de paris provenant même c'était
tragique parce que c'était les
collections c'est la semaine des
collections d'ailleurs dans toutes les
collections ont été annulés moi j'ai
réussi à partir sur un avion et il ya
plein de gens qui sont restés et qui
n'ont pas pu s'embarquer nom s'était
séparé en vertu de lunettes ya pas des
passages de conclure je recommence en
revanche je te dire il avait tellement
parlé de ses incroyables mesure de
sécurité on va vous fouillez y en a pas
plus que plan visible ira pas à pareille
franchement on n'a pas volé les maliens
sur le fouillis
[Applaudissements]
oui
on va parler de l'autre j'ai dit on
nettoie la honte au monde le sait on en
parle plus la page est tournée la vie
continue c'est difficile mais elle
continue d'autant plus un mandat que
vous avez l'air de vous êtes bien remise
d'une certaine façon c'est à dire que je
je je plonge sais je suis un petit mc
canalise là j'avais toutes les semaines
chez un psy il est bien il est bien
imite nautiz comme il te prend cher
comme tous les petits canailloux je vous
rends pas compte que quoi
c'est un scandale pour combien de temps
une heure c'est bien alors il hypnotise
oui je ne sais pas ce qu'il fait quand
je suis le disais je tombe sur la tête
et de promis le bail finalement oui mais
quand je me réveille de mal au cul s'est
installée
believe it or qu'est ce que tu as envie
on ne passe pas par moi que tu
travailles tu as mal dit les choses et
donc sur les conseils de mon psy il m'a
dit sortez il faut pas risquer à la
maison implantée il faut sortir donc je
suis sorti c'est vrai alors d'un côté si
je sors tous les soirs et j'essaye de
m'étourdir de ne pas penser on dire bd
dont elle s'est vite consolé avant si je
reste chez moi pleurnicher on dira alors
fait un peu trop la dent de toute façon
personne négation et donc j'ai trouvé
deux charmants jeunes gens l'envoya
manuel casella mannequin italien de 26
ans et puis alors je sais pas qu'est ce
que je faisais ça allait pas avec manuel
casella
alors lire j'ai la chance qu'il existe
dans notre société des très beaux jeunes
gens qui sont gérontophile et tant qu'il
y aura de la gérontophilie s'émerveille
parce que j'adore les femmes un peu mur
n'en fout il y en a peut-être ici je
sais c'est naturel ils prennent rien du
tout ils sont fascinés
voilà et je dois dire que c'est vrai que
ça c'est amusant de sortir avec des
jeunes gens sont très jolies dents
manuelles et puis maintenant il ya
ricardo perna d'auzan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non la page 18 ans et à 30 ans lui henri
cardon est vieux il a 30 ans ricardo ch
il marcha cadets en revanche ricardo
vous entendait beaucoup parler de lui
parce qu'il est en train de tourner avec
madonna il commence en septembre
duffy en octobre le tournage du film de
madonna
mis en scène par son mari guy ritchie à
malte et vous entendrez beaucoup parlé
de mon petit ricardo que j'ai donc tous
et qui te pousser aussi
alors vous me disiez me disiez abondant
96 avoir des périodes de libido
déchaînés et puis ensuite des phases de
repentir et limite mysticisme pendant
pendant lesquelles vous refusez amep
dans deux tombes par une secte ou
sublimer tout dans la peinture est ce
moment là et aujourd'hui que d'encaisser
au jeu dans lequel ces nouvelles
pourtant c'est qu'il ya deux jours pour
la première fois j'ai repris mon pinceau
donc j'ai dans la phase mysticisme
peinture vous abandonnez la phase
libidum je n'ai pas peint depuis dix
mois c'est vrai que je me suis donc jeté
dans la libido
mais maintenant j'ai retourné un pinceau
je n'ai plus besoin je peut sublimer ses
optimistes ce que tu penses moment où
est ce que ce sombre tout dans des tons
sais pas si tu t'y connais en couleurs
en peinture c'est embêtant le haut de la
cuisse il n'y a pas de jury et va les
tons sépia sondés ton un peu marronnasse
un peu envie arrêt un pc une couleur qui
se garde côtes devrait te plaire
[Applaudissements]
et donc je peins dans cette tombe bien
alors c'est vrai vous êtes entourés de
beaucoup de mystère depuis toujours
est ce que c'est vrai par exemple que
vous êtes né en compte d'un père marin
n'était pas malin il était officier de
marine à la vite j'ai été élevé dans la
haine des hommes j'ai eu une éducation
religieuse 13 ans la haine enfin c'est
vrai que je vaux j'ai eu une éducation
religieuse c'est vrai et on me faisait
voir que les hommes disent ont abusé et
beaucoup les jolies jeunes filles est
bon je me sens tellement je me suis of
me suis toujours méfié cdd messieurs
peut-être pour ça j'ai toujours choisi
des êtres un peu faible vénérable alors
amende à petit on peut le dire vous
étiez assez moche à xavière l'appareil
un appareil vers android
ouais mais c'est vrai un appareil
dentaire il faudrait souriez aux ailiers
là j'avais tous les membres seraient
l'appareil un cauchemar par l'habituel
de fil de fer trop grande si trop maigre
trop grand trop maigre alors ceux qui
étaient donc au départ justement moi je
trouver des mots jetés et quattro grain
cromheecke trop plate et où en fait ça
s'est révélé être un avantage parce que
justement on cherchait des filles qui
était grande et maigre et que ça pour
faire mannequin bon alors ça tombait
bien comprendre ce verdict était très à
la mode à l'époque c'était c'était un
petit peu le lot que françoise hardy
ouais c'est ça oui et alors comment vous
êtes retrouvés à londres à la grande
époque du swinging london comment c'est
arrivé ça oui j'étais dans une agence de
mannequins sable et catherine harley qui
avait des tas de belle fille johanna
shimkus etc et elle m'avait envoyé à
l'un d'entre vous j'en vois les couilles
en place de valium le temesta d'accéder
directement dans des mois là j'étais
sous anti dépresseurs
finalement c'est aussi bien sans
attendre sous ricardo cette agence de
mannequins qui m'a envoyé à londres
catherine arles et donc à londres
c'était l'époque du swinging landes de
la wii la mode venait de londres et il y
avait aussi que la marie courante etc
qui avait lancé la mini jupe et donc
j'étais à londres et je suis tombée
amoureuse dans rolling stones voilà
brian jones pour un comme suit et on va
voir un peu vos amants célèbres jimi
hendrix
oui non bon bah bah j'ai jamais couché
avec sonia dridi la coucher chez moi à
pas pareil c'est pas vrai pour tous
bryan ferry c'est vrai sa série était
est un garçon charmant marié père de
famille mission david bowie
oui oui je pense à sa page a duré un an
beau oui oui oui j'ai plus un peu plus
d'un an c'est vrai oui et vous dit en
parlant de bo xt plus imaginatifs qui
avec bryan ferry et c'était vraiment pas
que sorti avec un garçon qui se maquille
plus que moi bryn jones donc
effectivement il est besoin d'une maman
brian jones était là il le relève étonné
d'être maternés chic est mort donc isolé
peut il avait besoin comme ça qu'on
s'occupe de lui
voilà et puis un jour vous allez chez
ses parents c'est tout il ya pas un
compagnon de la chance
non je me suis arrêté à une certaine
époque je me suis rendu compte que je ne
voulais plus coucher avec des gens qui
faisait plus ou moins le même métier que
moi donc dorénavant ce ne sont que des
gens hors du métier des inconnus anonyme
des plombiers
n'y pas pas du chu alors quand
corporation donc dû à quoi alors
plombier on arrive au peintre parce
qu'un jour amanda lear arrive chez
castel vous tombez sur dali qui vous dit
vous avez la plus belle tête de mort que
j'ai jamais vu est ce que vous aviez
quoi des fossiles à maquillage très
blanc seing
c'est à dire je venais défilé pour paco
rabanne encore à bonne à l'époque où
bach et beaucoup la banane tout ça et
j'étais assez spectaculaire puisque je
sortais chez paco rabanne et d'al hima
vue très maigre trait au sol et il a dit
ah quel beau squelette alors moi on
m'avait jamais dit j'ai un beau
squelette on m'avait dit tu as un beau
cul ou des belles jambes en squelette et
j'ai pas pris ça pour un compliment
alors il a dit mais si je vous assure
vous avez la plus belle tête de mort que
jamais et donc sudistes mais qu'il est
cinglé en plus et immo france je ne plus
jamais le voir c'était une très mauvaise
impression de départ mais c'est comme
dans les films américains
ça commence toujours par des passionnés
alors là vous digéré cgt séduite après
voilà là vous vous débarquez à l'hôtel
meurice avec une faune seulement
incroyable alors vous dites les gars ce
goût eelv et l'ambassadeur d'espagne
avec le coach il quitte son pays puis
défaut cierges seul édifice vrai on en
trouvait plus il y avait de tout des
coiffeurs des du coucher avec lui oui
dali pendant 15 16 ans c'est vrai que ça
a était une
une relation très très très intenses
parce que c'était à la fois mon petit
ami mon père mon amant mon professeur de
dar al ahly excusez moi mais je le dis
souvent c'est dans cette émission et je
le répète encore ce soir
gala 10 est formidable elle disait si
mon mari est heureux avec amanda je suis
heureuse j'aimerais que beaucoup de
femmes prennent exemple
non je sais je sais je sais comme moi
même que c'est extrêmement jalouse je
n'envisage absolument pas de de dire à
mon fiancé mon mari mon ami oui oui vous
tapez bon c'est pas le cirque le gala
comme avec dix ans de plus que davie est
très très très forte sur la chose cette
époque non plus oui elle est même
franchement dit elle m'a dit que je suis
tellement soulagé que vous soyez là
comme ça va aller avec lui à toutes les
soirées les machins là chez soi je suis
tranquille je vais au théâtre
tranquillement j'ai bien mériter ça elle
écrivait son journal et vous faisait le
boulot voilà quoi mais vous en faites
vous dit si ça vous arrive et vous
diriez qui sait cette [ __ ] décolorés
qui vient me piquer mon jules
alors outre mystère évidemment vous le
connaissez vous le savez parce que ma
fille zone a souvent parlé vous avez
même dit à pitbull finalement pas si ya
pas de baffie kahn a parlé c'est de
jouer comme que ce soit en résolve le
problème il ya quelques mois j'ai
regardé une des émissions et tu recevais
rocco siffredi rocco siffredi et alors
ça m'a beaucoup viré parce que tu disais
à roko y at il une femme
avec qui tu aimerais coucher et il à
dire mandali c'est vrai parce qu russe
aimerait justement enfin découvrir ce
fameux mystère et c est bon ensuite j'ai
revu rocco siffredi et alors il s'agit
là pas de problème le seigle il est
charmant il est donc allé non je crois
qu'il a percé le jour même tu vois un
super macho comme lui un super état l'on
est fasciné bien sûr tout ce qui tourne
autour du mystère de l'ambiguïté l'un
sur pourquoi parce que justement les
filles d'aujourd'hui bon les arts 2 par
exemple de lecture n'avait dans ta
dernière émission est dangereux non plus
aucun sens vers elles se font pas désiré
et ça c'est ce qui manque
bond des commandes à lire est arrivé
pour lancer ses premiers disques avec
auréolé du nouveau mystère est ce que
c'est un homme est ce que c'est une
femme on ne sait pas d'où vient-elle
quel âge as tu es toutes ces conneries
la sacrée autour de moi nora demeestère
qui fascinait les gens la minute où ils
m'ont vu toute nue dans playboy
photographié sur ali ils ont intimé mais
je fais extrêmement déçu jeudi mais
c'est raide et presque voulu vite se
joue entre les autres amanda c'était un
coup marketing en fait c'était un coup
marketing de très mauvais goût mais qui
a vachement bien fonctionné puisque
vingt ans après tu en parles en
canonnant parlera vous seraient mortes
comment par là encore on pense qu'on se
rappellera pas de méchants sûr on est
peut-être même pas de mes tableaux mais
on se rappellera amanda lear qui s'était
déjà celle là ab oui celle dont 10 est
perçue elle se passe quoi on touche au
plus profond de l'identité de chacun de
nous fait
non la vente annoncée de l'économie en
parler maintenant des gens il faut les
ventes aussi son nom mais tout le monde
se demande au fond de moi suis-je [ __ ]
suis une lesbienne à 10 h la part de
mystère reste entière moi
personnellement pas pour moi et pour moi
en tous les cas
non ce qui est extraordinaire laurence
il ya des spécialistes italiens qu'on
fait des agrandissements b continue si
l'amendé à lire nullement parce que les
poils pubiens des hommes et des femmes
sont pas plantés dans le même sens il y
avait des photos dans playboy bron très
explicite quand même belle photo
d'ailleurs et il avait mis avec des
loupes il avait agrandi les poils
pubiens on ait pu bien on voit dans quel
sens y pousser voilà je ne savais pas ça
mais par ex des garçons c'est vraiment
plus pas dans le sens critique ont
décollé de trouver quoi les hommes ont
le plus simple le plus un gamin mandat
pour faire taire la rumeur serait quand
même étrange ne les habite le faire
comme sheila de faire un enfant
non faut déjà trouver la mer
je suis contre j'ai tous les addicts ré
so so so she trop vieille maintenant
mais même et en plus j'ai toujours dit
que dans le showbiz on ne devait pas se
reproduire
1 les vedettes sont des monstres faut
pas qu'ils se reproduisent
tu te vois toi ayant une maman qui met
des fossiles qui va à la télé au lieu
d'amener à l'école tous les matins ce
jeudi matin c'est pas une maman ce
rappelé que ce soit mon chéri maintenant
je pars en tournée pendant six mois où
tu as une vraie maman ou alors c'est pas
une maman c'est une vedette de cinéma ce
binôme
alors pour savoir la vérité il faudra
attendre l'autopsié sauf si vous fait
incinérer
oui peut-être c'est pas ou alors ceci je
ne meurs pas oui comme d'habitude quand
j'avais fait rien comme tout le monde
alors j'ai été animatrice c'était un peu
tous étaient restés les chanteuses
actrices de cinéma
et là vous sortez un single qui est
magnifique c'est comment on fait ça
s'appelle love boat on écoute souvent
dans cette émission amanda vient de
faire une reprise
génial
[Musique]
ouais
[Musique]
faire une interview oui non et vous ne
répondrez amanda lear que par oui ou par
non
[Musique]
le chemin original
vous avez bougé par le djing à la mort
d'un sergent peut rallumer désolé ok on
allume heures désolé on va faire une
interview
oui non on a bouffé
bien amanda lear si vous trompiez votre
jules est ce que vous lui diriez non est
ce que vous croyez en dieu
ouais est-ce que vous donnez dans la rue
à ceux qui font la manche
oui mais il ya des trucs que vous
refusez de fer au lit oui quoi je me
suis plié j'ai moi même
bien sûr tous piégés oh là là j'aimerais
savoir qui a des trucs dégoûtant on en
amour bien des salles à mangalore
est ce qu'on dit à chaque fois pareil on
s'embrasse sur la bouche avec la langue
des trucs comme ça il ya des trucs pas
mondaine gens aiment faire et moi par
particulière pourquoi un exemple la
vaisselle c'est trop écoute a des poils
plein les dents après avez vous réalisez
vos rêves d'enfants n'ont quand même pas
fait le plus beau conclure par un
président de la république far tu
aspires devenir après quand je dis tu
assures tu voudrais voir un président un
jour non
amanda est ce que vous avez déjà eu des
expériences diensten sexe vous
rencontrez quelqu'un pour rencontrer
quelques abris oui une demi heure après
dans les chiottes du restaurant pour une
dernière d'accord
et les remparts et un thé un raptus dans
l'ascenseur ça vous est arrivé déjà dame
est allée elle me riez vous devenir
amanda lear la maîtresse d'un chef
d'état oui un lieu aux amateurs magie le
pouvoir que tard c'est toi qui dirige
pasqua ait tout ce que tu lui un mandat
avez vous déjà connu la dépendance
sexuelle
oui non mais c'est quelque chose de
terrible grog swinguant dix mecs gelé
dans la peau à la dea qui nous touche ça
pose un sa bouge et tous et c'est
dramatique
est ce que vous croyez avant de dire
qu'il ya quelque chose après la mort oui
des compositions vous avez déjà fait
l'amour à 5 à 5
non c'est beaucoup c'est évidemment par
des soustractions attend à 5 de masina
taille du lit ak non à trois temps à aa
car oui ah oui oui car oui oui oui il y
avait des femmes non les animaux
amanda lear avec vous plus de qualités
que de défauts non oui y at il un
fantasme que vous n'avez pas réalisé
oui ma fille en même temps maintenant
c'est vrai il faut il faut de toute
façon qu'est toujours un fantasme non
réalisées pendant quand on a réalisé
tous ses fantasmes d'abord on a plus que
des bons souvenirs sur des fantasmes et
puis la vie est triste faut toujours
espérer encore de faire quelque chose
amanda lear est ce que vous vous aimez
non c'est pas encore ça regarde ni
intervenir travaille là dessus et mon
psy ce cépage et en hiver vote ces
maladies qui les connaissances enfants
est ce que vous feriez un film porno
pour un million de francs non 2 millions
non non mais j'y mourrai posé la
question il ya 15 ans j'aurais dit oui
parce que je trouve que j'étais encore
photographia alors maintenant ça
vieillit jolie attend à partir d'un
certain âge je trouve quand même les
hommages de l'iremam tellement faux
sophie millions de francs laurent est un
gâchis
ainsi 200 millions je pourrais pas
veillé à non j'ai pas de la rue alors
est il mort né
jackal macarons ali
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous étaient en compagnie de l'amiral
philippe de gaulle oui un grand
admirateur d'amanda lear qui j'avais
demandé quelle femme il souhaitait avoir
avec lui ce soir et on refaire l'amiral
me dit on dans l'île a dit je veux
amanda lear vous êtes revu depuis
non non c'est fini on en est resté là
mais je plais beaucoup aux hommes
politiques
c'est compris un texto il parle ce
rendez-vous vous savez ça c'est vrai ah
oui il paraît d'après michel tauriac il
est resté très très imprégné de cette
rencontre et j'en passe et j'en enyeama
premièrement juste au dessus vous
plaisait beaucoup aux vieux vous un non
c'est pas parce que là on va parler on
va parler de salvador d'avis alors ont
publié chez michel lafon vous aussi un
livre qui s'appelle monde ali à
l'occasion du centenaire de la naissance
de salvador dali en 1904 voilà alors au
delà de la caricature généralement
véhiculée par les médias
c'est à dire le je suis fou du chocolat
lanvin l'anagramme de son nom a vida
dollars voilà vous essayer de montrer un
délit un peu plus frais après le mot
réhabiliter mais c'est vrai que dali
souffre d'une très mauvaise image on se
rappelle de lui en effet la caricature
le type qui voulait choquer le
provocateur les moustaches rigolote etc
on oublie un petit peu que c'était quand
même un peintre fantastique un
dessinateur incroyable et puis surtout
un génie et alors c'est sa faute de
toute façon comme tous les gens qui
aiment provoquer gainsbourg pareils
quand ils voulaient les billets ils
savent très bien qu'en provoquant ils
vont se faire taper dessus mais mais
c'est plus fort qu'eux il peut pas s'en
empêcher
pareilles ma fille selon la provocation
ça va il peut il sait pas où on peut
s'arrêter et donc daly était comme ça et
je le déplore parce que je mangeais
connu un dali l'être humain ces
faiblesses gentillesse son humour et eau
et non pas l'homme public l'homme
publiquement il mettait franchement
antipathique ce n'est que dali l'homme
public c'est pas c'est tout ce que j'ai
testé moi je voyais ce mec avec une
limousine un chauffeur qui dépensait des
fortunes et du ceram de l'époque du lait
seront closes riez je touche l'époque le
mandat a chuté de gauche à l'époque et
ça me choquer beaucoup c'était pensée
mai 68 et tout ça paraît douteux
bouderaient la foufoune oui et est donc
en rencontrant dali et quand ça va on a
dit de moi pour isoler mettre ça sur le
nez un tandem retour et plein de boutons
voilà c'est un gros chêne avec ces
[ __ ]
alors avant dans votre livre parle de
dali mais au delà de dali vous raconter
deux époques absolument fabuleuse
d'abord c'est le le swinging london
c'était les années soixante à londres
avec les beatles les stones brian ferry
david bowie et les années soixante dix à
new york avec warhol paloma picasso
diane de furstemberg donc c'est un livre
à la fois raconte un grand peintre et en
même temps trace le portrait d'une
époque c'est bien oui parce que je
préside ce n'est pas ma biographie c'est
vrai de dali mais comme dali connaissez
le monde entier c'est vrai qu'à travers
lui j'ai rencontré ses côtés des gens
jamais je n'aurais espéré mais basé dans
la rue wahou livre comment 165 quand
vous rencontrez ce ladder dali vient
tous les deux en train de pisser chez
castel c'est vrai que les pompiers
[Applaudissements]
dallier il était très pipi caca c'est
vrai on le coupe on peut couper le
souffle et on va tout il était très en
voix tensions rencontrées dalli je sais
que ces histoires amanda et nam et oum
annoncé que vous êtes une table sûrement
s'en fout que j'allais sa montre et
nouveau simple pourquoi encore 21
échographie non une échographie ou les
qu'on passe en direct mais volontiers
que vous avez un médecin ici qui peut
qui peut s que vous êtes prêt à vous
faire part en baisse à la télévision
[Applaudissements]
vous rencontrez d'avis quand vous
rencontrez dali donc vous êtes avec
votre fiancée de l'époque et irlandais
ce qui s'appelle tara oui d en compagnie
de brian jones et donc vous rencontrez
sauveur dalit à l'époque il se fait
appeler le divin le divin d'allier jour
il aimait bien ça ils donnent des
surnoms à tout le monde sauf à vous
parce qu'il vous a appelé souvent c'est
à dire qu'il ne reconnaît pas le nom des
gens c'était impossible pour lui c'est
toujours approximatif c'est pas et
roselyne bachelot ready cash à lauryn
hill à la sonorité comme ça il a
rencontré sylvie vartan et incarne se
rappeler si leur temps ils appeler
cécile bertrand la sonorité c'était un
petit peu ça et donc été préféré donner
des surnoms comme il le rappelle thierry
paraire dix ans il pouvait pas se
rappelèrent 10 ans alain decaux non il
aurait dû pour l'histoire ou qu'elle y
sont voilà ou quelque chose comme ça qui
est aussi leur donner des surnoms dont
un très joli chinoise il appelait le
gars de rouge
voilà bien et il ya même un double louis
xiv y avait une dame blonde avec des
cheveux très bouclés être imposants
plein de bijoux il disait c'est le roi
louis xiv il a pris le 4e rang à tester
donc il parlait tout le monde comme ça
au masculin et je dois dire que
s'apprêtaient beaucoup à confusion déjà
l'écho alors au début vous le trouvez
quand même chez shawville à un peu gras
vous trouvez un peu ridicule au départ
non un peu prétentieux penser qu'à
l'époque moi je j'étais très attiré par
les chanteurs rock et guitariste et ça
donc c'était mon truc c'était plutôt les
mains avec des cheveux longs et tout et
je vois ce monsieur qui était plutôt
antipathique avec des moustaches on
voyait un kilomètre qui se maquillent et
en plus avec du crayon noir et tout anti
membres à ses portes et samoussas gérer
clairement une question est donc c'est
vrai qu'il m'a pas paru trop sympa et en
plus de ça c'était pas on prenne préféré
d'autres choses et les beaux-arts et
j'adorais picasso est pas du tout là
des dalits alors évidemment tout le
monde seulement les jeux que vous êtes
taper dali et il ya des révélations dans
votre bouquin il était en fait fasciné
par les par les prouesses sexuelles de
sa cour mais lui d'après ce qu'on
comprend ce qu'il était impuissante des
voyeurs quoi les regarder c'est à dire
qu'ils étaient tous en train de chercher
défi pour poser pour lui
or quand on a une très jolie fille et
qu'on lui dit vous voulez vous
déshabiller mademoiselle entièrement nue
pour la rassurer évidemment la fille
sadie va me sauter dessus c'est un vieux
cochon dont pleurer sur itélé rue je
suis impuissant devant elle songerait
toujours
et alors ça rassure et les filles dont
il disait tout le temps je suis
impuissant m'enfin les gens qu'ils
disent tout le temps tu sais grand bien
et on s'est aperçu petit à petit qu'ils
ont fait n'était pas vraiment impuissant
il aimait bien se donner cette image et
il était surtout très cérébral comme
beaucoup d'artistes où son génie c'est s
était pas l'acte physique tripoter
quelqu'un qui intéressait c'était tout
ça parce france en profite pour vos
palper un petit peu ma fille a longtemps
[Rires]
non vraiment ça n'intéresse que les
tuiles du tout hors saison s'intéressent
pas la place aux premières rencontres et
vous demande si vous êtes lesbiennes oui
ça aussi ça l'intéressait beaucoup
comité un peu voyeur il aimait bien
savoir que les filles des lesbiennes
entre elles les mecs pdc alors moi j'ai
tout ça ça m'intéresse pas remettre en
place et lui étaient pas homo il avait
essayé et il avait fait quelques
chaleurs car
garcia lorca qui avait essayé par ses
avocats était amoureux de lui et daniel
est pas dit non d'ailleurs messagerie
c'est mal
[Rires]
arrivent en nombre cette sodomie avait
été arrêté à mi parcours est là a passé
haut débit paris ça fait très mal c'est
par la première fois amanda alzheimer
[Rires]
paraît-il que voilà mettez fétichiste
ils adorent et vos pieds par l'essence
est réduite bunuel toute cette période
la peinture réaliste
les bottines lacées tous ces trucs à
savoir plus d'enfants [ __ ] un pied
c'est pas évident et il aurait gagné
mais les robins des bois parce qu'il
aimait beaucoup tout ce qui était un
humour un petit post je suis sûr qu il
aimait beaucoup rire il a donné rigoles
ex et il aimait vous qu'elle s'appelait
girard setti à john dillinger sorti avec
une sérieuse et se transformer en
paradis qui se souvient de gérard sétif
il a joué dans van gogh en affûtant
souvient soeur bravo serbe
voilà et donc alors oui il ya une
histoire extraordinaire donc c'est que
dali était marié avec gala la fameuse de
galles avant dix ans la première vente
contre ivo van à elle comme un
inspirateur
il ya les formidables les marches il est
très maladroit et c'était très important
pour lui que gala m'accepte présidence
était la femme légitime il allait pas le
dire j'ai rencontré une fille super je
voudrais qu'elle vient vivre à la maison
bon c'était mal barré un nom qui m'a dit
faut que vous fassiez bonne impression
alors moi j'ai fait un effort je me suis
maquillée bien tout ça et quand josé
présenté à gallas était le pire bilan
parce que ils n'arrêtaient pas de
regarder regarde ma petite chérie
car comme elle est belle tournez-vous un
monde inconnu au fait de voir vos jambes
et sera égal à la tire une tronche en
plus d'aligner comme un aspirateur mais
je vous assure elle est rentrée bien qu
elle est très intelligente tu verras
puis elle part plusieurs manches et gala
de plus en plus c'est le jeu mais qu'est
ce que c'est que cette gonzesse et tout
ça danse et s était pas bien du tout
alors vous mangez beaucoup lors de ce
premier dîner
moi je
gala dit qu'est ce qu'elle mangeait
alors des étudiants c'est la politesse
hélas cette phrase terrible dit si vous
étiez poli vous viendriez pas chez moi
avec une mini jupe qui montre tout quoi
bref c'est elle à l'époque de marie
cointe et une mini jupe dont moi ça vous
voyez je prendrai le club jouera de la
food & et envoyé est égal à l examen
tous annoncés s'est pas fait bonne
impression la première fois ça a été
terrible puisque très sympathique de la
part de gala c'est que finalement elle
part en voyage elle vous donne de liga
là je me disais mais moi j'ai mon mari
elle était folle de son mari et mon mari
est heureuse avec un mandat voilà je
suis heureux ce moment voilà quand henry
c'est énorme ça c'est énorme et
notamment au caire or là vous raconter
dali peintre qui détestait les femmes
qui faisait de la peinture parce qu'il
disait que le génie est dans les
couilles et comme moi quand j'ai annoncé
ma mort ou non le talent justement ces
messieurs réside là dedans et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs ils disaient qu'ils sont
impuissants ils font pas des enfants on
peut pas faire des enfants quand on est
michel-ange ou léonard de vinci
donc tout ça est sublimé et ça te sort
partons pinceaux devant ce que je
voulais éviter ça et alors il rêvait la
chambre votre bouquin c'est qu'on fait
cette dalle il avait un [ __ ] qui
recopier les photos il est parti réalise
des tableaux qui s'appelait dans ce
tableau il ya des partis un peu chiante
à faire le 1 sont le ciel comme ça donc
bea était un brave petit artisan qui
faisait ça très bien et puis d'allier
après arriver alors et mettez les
touches génial externe est rythmée mais
j'ai beaucoup appris ces bois on le
regarde en banque et sur le béa qui
était son [ __ ] en fait étaient logés
comme un chien enragé petit bail mais ça
nous ravissent plaignez pas un litre
était tout le monde très mal c'est vrai
il faut le dire il n'était pas très
gentil avec ses collaborateurs car on a
compté le personnage dans la vie
quotidienne par exemple nettoyer jamais
ses lunettes
elle était très sale et comme il était
très choqué souvent ils voulaient pas
mettre ses lunettes
on y voyait pas grand chose du sauna
géré par exemple dans les taxis pour
permettre ces lunettes quand il y avait
encore à new york au compteur il sortait
des billets de 100 dollars et y donner
aux chauffeurs ayant le chauffeur et 100
dollars 200 dollars sampdoria avec les
trois dollars 56 super 350 $ et le
chauffeur d et 5 you must d'aller god
bless cru alors moi j'ai tout cafter à
gala et elle a arrêté de lui donner de
l'argent liquide et tricot de corps
salle qu'ils ont pu lever le matin il
est né beaucoup prendre son petit
déjeuner en tricot de corps est alors il
faisait tomber y tremper son croissant
dans du miel est alors le miel
dégouliner un petit peu sources entre
eux et puis avait des taches de café au
lait il aurait été un autre par deux
salles près de six ans était impropre
mais gardez le sale toujours en dessous
de ce cas il est mieux regarder comment
il était fait signer par les excréments
de rats par la pourriture
par exemple un soir ils vont dîner chez
chez un ami de dali un excellent plat il
y avait des traces d' excuses à
l'accueil et à la soirée aura lieu
d'avoir d'abord ce quelle solution
vraiment le 13 mai ou juin
il était très typique ac1 été arrêté il
est tombé en extase devant une énorme
crottes emploi et ses seuls verte de
nous sommes seuls et ils me disaient
mais regardez comme c'est bon oui
regardez à normaliser vous remet ça va
on continue venons mais non mais
regardez alors y regarder les ailes des
mouches la couleurs irisées c'était
assez répugnant l'évidence
mais aujourd'hui pour penser que je
pense que papa du talent parce que moi
maintenant je dois révélé une chose
c'est que quand on a écrit la première
pierre robin des bois d'à peu près
alexandre dumas on écrivait chez moi
dans ma cuisine et un jour peuvent
façonner et comme mois de janvier oui
c'est important ça va mais comme il
n'avait pas eu le temps de m'acheter des
fleurs il m'avait amené une crotte gelé
dans l'union la somme j'ai trouvé ça
incroyable de pouvoir prendre une crotte
congelés quoi ça va mieux le psy qu'est
ce qu'il en est mais confiant en fait
vous étiez très amoureuse de dali
simplement un certain je vous l'avais
connu le cas on entend trop tard quoi
c'est ça assez méconnu oui c'est vrai je
leur ai posé sur y est marié il était
fascinant il était cultivé il savait
tout ils avaient des anecdotes
invraisemblable me raconter c'est pas
ces rencontres avec hitchcock avec walt
disney avec marilyn monroe il avait
connu monde dont moi j'étais facile et
là maintenant je parle beaucoup mais à
l'époque je disais rien voir à écouter
et s'étaient battus les plus stricte
alors ils étaient aussi très possessif
parce que quand vous êtes avec david
bowie par exemple ils vous ont aidé à
david bowie
je n'aimais pas david bowie préchauffage
cooper il m'a dit qu'il souffre et avec
ce mec qui se maquillent plus que vous
et
non même pas beau il avance alice cooper
il ya le côté gore le côté allons vous
raconter tout ça vous raconter aussi
cette déchéance et dernière fois que que
vous le voyez en 1983 et je suis triste
la lumière il veut pouvoir dans le noir
on s'est rencontrés dans le noir total
il ne voulait plus que je me vois très
bien qu'il était un as vu les photos
elle lui donne un tuyau dans le nez tout
ça il y avait un certain exhibitionnisme
même à se faire voir c'est tout le temps
spectacle même mourant est malade et
tout mais visiblement ils avaient ils
avaient honte que je le vois comme ça a
été je veux vous rappeler toujours de
moi très beau très beau jeu vous brassez
va très beau très fringant et d'orienter
dans le noir complet et c'était assez
émouvant et puis après ça il a fini bien
tristement comme tous ces gens qui n'ont
pas d'enfant il est mort tout seul
entouré de gens qui voulaient faire du
pognon
dalli a disparu aujourd'hui si vous
étiez la muse d'un peintre voudriez être
la muse de quel point je ne sais pas si
aujourd'hui il y en a qui me fascine
autant parce que si c'est rigolo
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire avant de les ré so nous
avons déjà dit déjà dit désolé c'était
ma dernière paire en 48 ans l'a jamais
dit on me dit souvent these c'était ma
dernière faire en 41 min 41 s qu'on vous
a déjà dit toi ma chérie tu es les yeux
qui crie braguette
non mais c'est une bonne diction
pourrais vous le dire parce que c'est
tout à fait ça est ce qu'on vous a déjà
dit ça vous dérange pas que ma femme
regarde oui mais ça ça me plaît pas du
tout ce qu'on vous a déjà dit ça vous
dérange pas que ma mère regarde non non
on ne dit plus tôt surtout le dit pas ma
maman 1
je vous ai déjà dit ça vous dérange pas
si je demande à mes potes de nous
rejoindre
oui ça met de plus en plus on dit ça
parce que ça s'est passé c'est nouveau
cette histoire de d'échangisme et tous
les copains
alors moi qui suce cuistot pas partager
c'est pas mon truc ça mais c'est vrai
que c'est de plus en plus est ce qu on
vous a déjà dit merci pour cette nuit
mais désolé faut que j'y aille à un
conseil des ministres
oui dans l'horeca rui costa
non pas un conseil des ministres on me
dit des fois j'ai un concert où j'ai un
j'ai une interne stade de france
parce qu'on vous a déjà dit c'est quoi
ces prix exorbitants
[Rires]
non non est ce qu'on vous a déjà dit
rappelle-moi benito ça m'excite
même berlusconi non mais je ne suis pas
du tout le genre de berlusconi ça alors
je suis à ce point parce que dit il il
aime il est très belle fille d'ailleurs
italienne ou très traditionnelle c'est
là la belle italienne bien pulpeuse et
des poils sous les bras et oui c'est pas
du tout moi je suis pas du tout son
genre du tout
est ce que vous a déjà dit m et c'est
pas mes couilles ça
[Musique]
si amanda lear
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mandat ça la changera mandat
j'ai expliqué mes amitiés spectateurs
pourquoi vous êtes là d'abord parce
qu'on vous aime beaucoup et puis ensuite
parce que dans le deuxième tome donc de
de gaulle mon père
l'amiral parle de de gaulle et les
femmes donc quand on s'est vus pour
préparer cette émission je lui ai dit à
meyrals quelle femme souhaitez vous
avoir sur le plateau ce soir là et il
m'a dit amanda lear va la régente y
voilà oui pourquoi monde à lire mais pas
vous avez beaucoup d'esprit je vous ai
entendu avec philippe bouvard à grenade
l'aide des enseignants mais pas
seulement
il ya longtemps que je sais très gentil
mais un système ancien attaquant et je
veux j'ai remarqué que vous alliez de
l'esprit et du talent voilà dans les
entretiens télévisés en trop et voilà
mais aussi que vous avez une carrière de
chanteuse c'est vrai sans fin
voilà mandat donc ce qu'on peut dire
quand même c'est que tu es aujourd'hui
la femme que le fils du général de
gaulle souhaite voir aux produits sur un
plateau une vision tellement énervée
ado
bien
[Musique]
déclaré je ne sais pas si on se
souviendra de mes chansons plus tard
mais je suis sûr qu'on se rappellera
d'une chose on ne savait pas si j'étais
un homme ou une femme et vous avez
beaucoup joué sur cette ambiguïté amiral
est ce que c est ce que ces insectes un
garçon est ce que j'attendais qu'est ce
que c'est cette ambiguïté puisque vous
savez bien c'est des rumeurs qui ont
couru sur amanda lear est ce que c'est
cette ambiguïté fille garçon qui vous
séduit amiral normes y en a dans big 8
et chez le talent dont je m'occupe c'est
que je savais non parce que il faut dire
qu un amiral vous n'êtes pas le premier
et quand vous vous sachiez parce que
amanda a quand même déjà séduit ça dort
dali qui a adoré
amanda lear david bowie manuel casella
ricardo perna avec les cards au père
d'amanda
non non il n'est plus dans le paysage
onctueux libre mais non non non je ne
sais pas si j'étais libre non pas le
dernier carré une cité la regardons pour
merci beaucoup merci merci sa maison que
l'on jouera le nom rien
gg j'ai une vie amoureuse oui comme tout
le monde elle n'est pas faite pour vous
ennuie avec ça ici alors un mandat pour
accentuer votre voix grave et votre côté
androgyne qui ont séduit effectivement
beaucoup de gens la vue vous avant des
enregistrements de vos disques vous
fumiez des cigarettes et vous buviez du
whisky et alors ce que j'ai appris en
lisant le livre de l'amiral de gaulle
c'est que son père mais mais pas savoir
c'est à dire qu'il voulait changer sa
voix en général ils prenaient des
bassistes de travail une boîte et way we
lui trouvais qu'ils la voient trop rock
trop verts alliés oui quand un marron
d'inde
il l'aurait voulu j'aurais voulu avoir
une voix de basse voire mais c'est vrai
il a il n'aimait pas tellement ça voyez
par exemple la villa gillet face quand
il a dit à libération paris outragé
paris brisé paris martyrisé
il n'est pas content il n'y a pas du
tout contents de cette déclaration
précise jean moulin était trop émus gras
et
elle n'a pas trouvé bonne manne ne
convenait pas c'était à côté
oui mais sans toit dans la famille non
parce que moi alors maintenant je vais
te dire un mandat j'ai cherché l'amiral
j'ai cherché des points communs entre
toi à vandaele général de gaulle on
s'est tous remis à l'armée
je suis grande comme j'ai traîné cette
histoire de voix je suis vachement
content parce que je me suis dit amanda
qui fument des cigarettes qui boit du
whisky pour pour changer sa voile
général de gaulle qui trouve savoir trop
haut perchée donc là j'avais vraiment
trouvé comme le chante ont séduit la
voix les hommes politiques savent très
bien que la voie est très importante et
donc il séduit seller un secours qui
séduit donc ce sont des grands
séducteurs les hommes politiques je vois
aujourd'hui peut-être pas les budgets
des rôles de gaulle mais maintenant tu
regardes berlusconi tout ca et cc c'est
ce sont des acteurs presse qu'il s'avère
on leur écrit des textes il est un fait
devant la glace un geste et tout et
c'est très important et les les gens
comme moi qui fonda télévision du
spectacle c'est la même chose on sait
très bien que la voie est très très
important moi ma voix je peux la bonne
et je veux la faire plus basses plus
haute ce fut cédée à tendre la main dans
ce fait une voix pour rigoler comme ça
fait eu une voix de mecs comme ça ah non
mais pas que ça dit un truc pas faut
rigoler fait une boîte fille
[Rires]
nombreuses les soutiens de poids la
mairie micheline dax quoi oui alors
aidons
quand on écoute carmen des charmes de
cette opérette c'est que la voix très
basse à laquelle peut descendre la
cantatrice ce carmen elle-même vous
laissez des réseaux père est rejoint à
roues etc l opérette vous préférez de
tout rond je ne peux pas dire les mêmes
que celles qu'on des opérettes
d'offenbach
ah oui la belle hélène la belle hélène
je me suis un peu de la mélodie et tall
et ses doigts et bien c'est le choeur
antique qui est derrière et eefje les
réflexions ce qui est très intéressant
dans laquelle il a juré le peuple fait
des réflexions sur les vedettes qui
s'avance sur l'avant de la salle était
quoi l'air et lancé des grenades à
rebuts qui s'avance but qui s'avance but
que s'avance et agamemnon bleu roi un
barbu qui s'avance vue et 6h alors
question voix j'ai emmené comme des
porcs les gens l'en-but question
question voix j'ai trouvé des points
communs entre toi et le général de
gaulle malheur question amour pas du
tout le général de gaulle était vraiment
sur le sujet vraiment de l'amour disant
des tables et des gammes très sérieux
parce qu'on lui connaît finalement très
peu d' aventure en dehors de contrat -
toi on le connais très peu d' aventure
en dehors de tante yvonne de votre maman
il y avait une jeune femme à lille où le
début de la guerre de 14 mai qui est
décédé à ce moment-là il là ils
l'avaient une cousine éloignée qui avait
attiré son attention
thérèse elle est morte en guerre voilà
puis c'est tout et c'est tout enfin moi
j'ai un flirt avec ce joli film la
fidélité oui tu vas nous faire l'extase
aussi l'abstinence kamel à liestal juste
pour la fidélité à van baker bien tous
ses bons amis drague tout ce qui bouge
1 même quand ça bouge plus on y va
alors public je vous ai dit que s'ils
voulaient retrouver
arielle dombasle c'est lundi soir sur
france 2 et si vous voulez retrouver
amanda lear donc c'est sûr match tv de
sa belle tendance est en vente lundi
soir voilà et on vous retrouve dans
l'émission de stéphane bern oui sur
canal c'est entendre la semaine et puis
un film qui sort là qui s'appelle
archives de nuit et puis et puis je
travaille à un livre mais tout ça on en
parle en fait un parfait non non non
alors amanda vous restez avec nous ah
oui j'utilise un salut à vous faire là
mais on va libérer
franchement la libérer de la faim
[Applaudissements]
on a tous âges
[Musique]
en fait je voulais que philippe sorte
parce qu'on va faire une interview où là
dedans et dehors un nom maintenant
l'interview test
alors à mandali on va faire une
interview 15 pour en finir une fois pour
toutes avec cette histoire est si une
fille et un garçon moi personnellement
j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus mais
bon j'en veux plus j'entends parler de
ça et là on va savoir la vérité ma
dimension mondiale par la pluie
non je n'ai pas retrouvé le calme alors
on va savoir la vérité moi c'est en
vérité parce qu'on va poser des
questions très fine qui vont tout de
suite nous permettre de savoir si amanda
lear est une fille ou un garçon
il est fort ce thierry est ce que vous
savez faire un créneau oui bien sûr très
bien dans tous les cas nous on connaît
la réponse
alors est ce que est ce que amanda vous
comprenez les règle du hors-jeu au foot
ça le foot
ah non ça je suis déjà à la troisième
mi-temps à la rigueur mais l'enjeu non
ça suffit ça c'est la crise à l'égard de
ces pour toi c'est cadeau est ce que
vous pensez qu'en amour les
préliminaires sont importants oui les
prêts ligne en important et je dirais
même plus souvent il ya que les
préliminaires qui sont bien
elle adore ttc
[Applaudissements]
rester travailler l'un en tout cas les
gens peuvent voter chez eux
l'appel est surtaxée bien sûr mais c'est
intéressant
est-ce que tu bois une bière après
l'amour je suis endormi tout de suite
après avoir fait l'amour dans après
avoir finalement je viens appelle un
taxi la bulle parti à man galli quand
avez vous eu envie de vous gratter les
couilles pour la dernière fois
d'ailleurs c'est une chose que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi vous vous grattez
vous les couilles vous avez des points
c'est incompréhensible à la fouille ne
comprend pas pour nous enfin c'est pas
nous on se gratte pas on n'a pas si on
est propre
je vous pose de gratter la dernière fois
avec moi non je veux bien gratter celle
d'un monsieur qui me le demandent très
gentiment mais avec les ongles que j'ai
[Musique]